no jet oh it does work okay test you
also have one huh I think it works yeah
I don't hear it loud okay
I think you're sorry so um we're
Dennison Ben from booking com
we're both called data scientists there
I've been work I've started my third
year now you are wrapping up your first
year and I think it was a quite
interesting first two years we had a we
are purl based company so it's a bit
weird that we're standing here on a PI
data conference when I started we were
all using pearl as analyst as well which
I thought was really strange if you look
at the community of analysts worldwide I
think Python and our are the biggest
languages and during those two years we
also switched quite fast almost everyone
uses Python now and are some still do
use Perl and that's this is really a
much more convenient we like it a lot
and we also have a really nice year last
year because dennis joined you brought
some ideas to the floor like trying out
spark you used in a previous company and
we spent six months
diving deep into with using an existing
project that we worked on to try it out
whatever it would improve and the
quality of our predictive model went up
like crazy the performance was really
awesome working with spark was so nice
and so much better than using reducer
scripts with Python in - who sees and so
we fell in love we trained the entire
company almost and many people are using
it now and we really like it a lot
so for hackathons we also like to play
around with it see ok my clicker doesn't
work
it does so for Agathon we can work two
days a month on stuff we like and I like
to play around with spark and our
streaming came out with Christmas for
Python so we have four days to play
around you like doing a Bayesian
statistics so we were both playing
around with two different things and we
try to merge them together to see if we
could create a sequential test testing
engine using spark streaming and to
monitor our experiments continuously the
idea being that we could speed up our
decision making process for experiments
so normally you have to specify in
advance how what power you need and how
long if the weight and how many
observations and then you have to wait
but in the meantime people are peeking
and sometimes they see piece values that
are pretty extreme and I either stop it
or they yeah so we think based on
literature that the basin approach would
be much better for this case and we also
want to improve the quality of our
statistics so decrease the chance of
false positives and negatives and also
we are a bit geeky so we like to play
around with tech streaming so that was
our Agathon approach and that's also
disclaimer for this talk we haven't
productionize what we are discussing
today we're investigating it and we
think it's already really cool to share
we try to be as transparent as possible
what we use we're linking to articles
and papers that we've used and that
should help you to find out whether it's
suitable for you and we are we have some
examples of what we tried it out but
don't expect really revolutionary things
from this we're just starting and
investigating it so who has already got
any experience with spark streaming in
the room except for hold on okay that's
a couple of hands sir you want to
explain what you have been doing thus
far yeah scream
and in is it working yes okay so I'm
working a tribe in CC and we are doing a
lot of internet monitoring stuff and
especially bgp monitoring maybe know
about protocol who is responsible for
our for our teen and it's like like
worldwide project who does internet bgp
monitoring and we have a like a BGP
stream from various points around the
world and we're trying to use spark
swimming with Kafka to do real-time
particular analysis to detect by us BGP
hijacking or leaking all fun stuff and
yes like a one of our applications it's
not in a production stage we're also
playing with it a bit but it's kind of
cool technology and we way to help you
with intermediate results okay and I saw
a couple hands warm I think that's
behind you no okay
someone else maybe I feel so lonely
where we don't have that many people to
talk about spark streaming in our
company so it's nice to meet up other
people who also use it maybe that last
one and I'm curious sorry you have to
run all the way to D yes we try to use
spark streaming for predictive
maintenance
I'm from wärtsilä what self-produced
ship engine there's a sensor attached to
engine they transfer the data we use
cough cough flu to push the data to a
spark and run machine learning to
predict the failure mode okay yeah cool
thanks
so we started in Christmas and we did a
really basic thing we were parsing our
events for the customer service
department and we try to find out which
languages were depleted in resources as
so if if something happens in a certain
country and people are calling then we
want them to
be alert as soon as possible that the
people who speak French or some other
language are really constrained for
resources and they need help then we can
help as soon as possible
so that was a simple use case we tried
out just parsing and and counting we
haven't done any predictive stuff yet
but yeah for this case we also tried out
with experiment with the Bayesian
statistics and experimentation for the
rest spark streaming is a mini batch
processing framework so events that you
would normally process in batch so say a
day of data you now process them every
second or five seconds or 10 seconds or
whatever thresholds you've set and then
within that 20 seconds batch interval
you do stuff that is interesting and you
save it to a place that people can reuse
or you visualize it as you see in that
picture that I think almost everyone
copy-paste who explains streaming you
have a source of data going into spark
streaming source being Kafka I think
that's a really popular source we use it
as well and then you save it back to
HDFS so people who use hive can access
your data or you visualize a dashboard
and the nice thing about Parkinson's is
that it automatically recovers from
failures so if things break then it's
pretty good at recovering which is a
really important thing because yeah
things break especially on the big scale
it dynamically balances resource usage
which is nice and you can also enrich
your data so if you have an integer
coming in and at the integer maps to a
certain city and that city has a lot of
descriptive statistics ready and waiting
in a different table you can just
receive the integer with the city ID and
then reach it and do all kinds of stuff
with it because SPARC and have cached
data ready and it's also really nice and
everything you can do is Park the the
sequel engine machine learning library
you can apply that to your stream so
it's really powerful and we're really
happy with this 1.6 also added Python to
the list of supported or yeah it was
already there but now they're sitting in
Kafka at the direct stream which is
really helpful that was suddenly
available for Python as well so we tried
it out and we feel really happy that we
now have access to our life they
normally developers have that so they
have all kinds of custom libraries in
pearl in our company and they use it but
for analysts we are not used to process
things and batch the day after or the
week after which is fine in many use
cases and perfectly normal but I think
you can imagine use cases where you want
speed and you want to know things as
soon as possible so we're now building
real time data products smile this is a
bit of the infrastructure I will use it
so beginning top left we have I think I
also had a laser right do you have a
laser on this thing okay it doesn't work
anyway we have people using our website
they're looking for hotels for cities
and they're generating employ events so
top right there's a blog post written by
the guy who is maintaining our event
store we have billions of events per day
we have more than hundred megabytes per
second and six terabytes a day in events
and by far that is not in the far
matured is not interesting for me as an
analyst I really want a small soft
stream of that big stream of events and
we use a combination of ryuk and pro
modules to look into every event that's
being generated and then create sub
streams for example a customer service
upstream or a hotel using our back-end
system sub stream or a people using the
front end of a sub stream so we create
all these these specific nice rivers of
data they go into Kafka Kafka Dan
yeah people connect allows other clients
to connect with spark streaming being
one of the clients and yeah once it's
there you can we can finally use it
that's basically how we set it up
they're still quite a delay in in this
pipeline I think if we have around 20
second 30 second delay but still waiting
a day and a half versus 20 seconds is
still quite an improvement so we're
quite happy to have this opening we do
have some challenges so if there are
consultants who are really specialized
in this stuff or people we want to be
working with the stuff I know a lot
please reach out you can find me on
LinkedIn and
here's to hookup for people who have
more experience and have things running
smoothly because I still have some some
hiccups to deal with and that's
basically all I wanted to share about
spark streaming because yeah we also
wanted to dig into the the
experimentation part but sooo yeah so
let's assume that this is working
we prototype that that works and we are
you keeping track life of the amount of
people in a certain experimentation
variance and given that then we dive
into the experimentation part so this is
maybe a bit insulting to refresh the a
be testing stuff but in essence you want
to test a new variant maybe if you're a
landing page or you have a different
color scheme or you have a different
flow or whatever you change and then we
test it out by the dividing the traffic
you do it 50/50 or maybe 5% goes into
the variant and the rest stays normal
and after a time you observe which group
has the highest conversion rate or a
different metric and you put that
version for long and you improve your
product and this is the core of our
company company everything that people
propose or suggest she has to go through
this this process yeah so it's really
essential that this works smoothly so we
have hypothesis testing the mu-1 mu-2
being the means of the different groups
the null hypothesis the alternative
hypotheses and p-values are crucial
being result of chi-square testing where
p-values probability under the
assumption that the null hypothesis is
true of obtaining result equal or more
extreme than what was actually observed
denis pushed me to read it out loud
instead of paraphrasing my own p-value
definition so given this Dennis would
you like to go into the base and stuff
or one do you want to share a joke first
maybe without your five joke are you
prepared to store but I think is too
nervous to share it now so okay do your
serious stuff then okay is this still
your slide I think
yeah yeah but I can also explain it so
if you do I post stuff like this you
want to you make your hypothesis it's
normally that there's no difference
between the groups so the means equal
each other and you want to contradict
that so that's already kind of weird
setup I think because you investigate
the opposite thing that you really want
to show because you want to show that
there is the difference and this set up
you can do two kinds of errors so first
is if you say there was an effect but
there wasn't and the other one is if
there was an effect and you cannot
detect it so that's what's a weaker
because this will be important later and
so a Pakistan I looked into a Bayesian
I'd be testing because the reason for
that was a lot of big companies became e
testing companies changed to Bayesian
and we were very interested why and if
it could also be useful for us and I
think it has some very very nice
properties where we can really gain a
lot film so as we kept the bathroom I
think most of you know that there's so
we want to estimate the probability of
our hypothesis H given some data it's
called here evidence in the slide and
you can reformulate that with Bayes
theorem and the probability of the
hypothesis itself times the probability
of the data given the hypothesis divided
by the probability of the evidence so on
easy example for example would be you
want your hypothesis is it will rain
tomorrow and your data is weatherman
said it will rain and then you go over
to the other side and the probability of
your hypothesis so that it will rain
tomorrow is for answer them very high
for example and the other one a
probability that the weatherman says it
will rain
given your hypothesis also very high and
we will don't need the lower term senses
just since it's just a normalization
term okay and for this talk I used as an
example is a bit about Nami our case
it's like the easiest model impatient
statistics but all of this will what I
show also works for general
distributions so normal case and higher
but there will be too heavy on the
mathematics so I bought it onto binomial
so if we have two groups a and B normal
a/b test would be we check conversion
rate so we have events person books at
booking.com or a thousand so we have a
zero one event which is a binomial
distribution and so your groups a and B
s can be thought of as a long row of
zeros and ones on your conversion where
it would be the probability of a booking
and what we wanna estimate is really
this p1 and p2 of the both groups so to
get the probabilities of the conversion
rate and then compare them to to each
other to see if there's a difference or
not bayesian way of doing this is taking
the beta as a cone yogurt so it's very
common to take as a distribution for
this piece the beta distribution beta I
put on here the definition but it's not
so important so if you wanna coats us
just import beta from Sify stats and
then [ __ ] forget about it
on the bottom is the beta function so
you know in the denominator and like on
the bottom of the page is an update whoo
so if you if you already observed some
data then you just count how many ones
so how many bookings were in your data
and how many misses so where that here
would be the number of hits so the
number of bookings and n would be the
overall number so an
- that is it's a number of misses and
then you can always update this so this
is what our secret process so if you
collected a thousand already a thousand
samples and you can always update this
so that's a goes very well also with
this batch processing in Facebook and
this beta you normally choose it it
looks like this um so when you do a
Bayesian model you always want to update
your prior belief so what you think into
your posterior so you collected some
data and you want to refine your model
with the collected data and here for
example you see that the beta function
was very flexible so if we would
estimate that there's maybe 70 percent
conversion rate on our page then you
could say okay I don't booking you could
say okay I take a very narrow beta
because I think it even if my new
version is good it they're not vary a
lot from this what I already observed or
if you say I'm totally unsure what's the
conversion rate will be then you just
take like the straight line that would
be an uninformative prior and then just
update from there so that's what gives
the modern no information before and so
this pricing is always what people say
ok Bayesian stuff is not objective
because normally when you start then you
say ok this is my prey I fell for some
conversion rate and it varies a little
bit about that but that's a subjective
opinion and I will leave it with that
for now but I will show you later away
how to fit objective quire's
so that's also you can also estimate
this price from data and then here I did
a very simple code example so we sample
two binomial distributions of size 1
million so it's a bit as each group had
1 million sample then I have a
conversion of 5% in the one group and in
the big group I also implement a lift of
1% now there would be like a normal a
better set up
and then you just collect the number of
hits that would be a a yeah some a so
the once the number of misses would be
BA and next step would be now simple
form a PITA so you update your beater
yeah took an uninformative prior you see
the ones and then you just update your
beta sample from that do the same thing
for the other group sample format and
then you can already say stuff about
probability so you can just say so I
sampled for my group a and my group B
from the beta function with
distributions and then I can already say
okay given the data I'm sure that beats
bigger than a sub is better than a by
98% almost which is pretty strong
compared to a p-value which almost tells
you nothing so the p-value will tell you
something like yeah yeah what Ben said
okay yeah yeah some plots so I plotted
here the John posterior also both you
can the the exact Society here is a
conversion rate of group a so from 0 to
1 the y-axis is the conversion rate from
0 to 1 for Group B so the mean and then
we just get the joint posterior so we
look how how is this these two groups
compared to each other so the middle
line if the if a point lies in the
middle line it would say ok that's
completely no difference between between
both groups and if it's higher then you
say I have more evidence for a therefore
B and if it's lower than you say I have
more evidence for a so this probability
that our show before would be just the
integral about over the half planes here
and then I plotted some updates of this
a B test so after this was like 20 cent
that you are completely unsure where
your parameter values are you see this
on the big with a big blob then you
collect some more data get more schewe
but you still have a lot on the side of
a so you think I'm more sure that B is
better but I'm not really sure
and collecting more and more data than
the blob gets smaller and in the end of
the test you see that all the
probability must lies above sir excess
and you say ok now I can accept so
that's the easiest way for a B test but
there's a much cooler way which I will
show you next screen first need some
definition for that that it's the
highest density interval that's the
Asian version of the confidence interval
ok let's skip some mass the definition
of so you can think of this just as a
water line so you look look where do I
have to when I have a water line and cut
this down to the x-axis where does 95%
of my probability mass lies so you just
go up and down and see if I take the
integral from left to right where's 90
where 95% of the integral some mass of
so integral to examples again with this
set up you can do a much nicer thing
that's called the rope there was done by
John Krueger in his little polemic
article Bayesian estimation supersedes
the t-test so hope is a very little
region around the zero and another nice
thing about the highest entity interval
is that we get so I I plotted here the
difference of the means of the group and
the posterior distribution of that one
nice one is that we get a real
probability distribution so we don't
have confidence interval that is random
but we can really say we are 95% sure
given the data that our that our point
lies inside this interval and then the
Rope is a small region around 0 because
if you are true to yourself there will
be always some difference between two
groups if you measure them because of
noise or because of whatever and you can
choose this interval by business value
so you say ok if I just have a loop that
is very very tiny
point one percent then I don't care so I
just don't care and I wouldn't put it
for long also if I lose a little bit
then I also don't care that that expense
is zero to a complete interval and you
can look where your identity interval
lies compared to this to the slope and
then you get the following two decision
words so a parameter value is not
credible or rejected so you accept h1 if
the complete HDI lies outside the world
and on the other hand it's a complete
HDI falls inside the world you can even
accept your null hypothesis which is
also completely not possible and normal
testing so you can also only reject with
p-values not accept it just pretty nice
I think okay and this the set up makes
also sequential testing possible here's
a plot for my recent article of two of
some Stanford professors that work for
Optimizely that is what happens if you
do sequential testing with a normal
pvalue so that will mean you take a
sweatshirt maybe alpha equals point one
and then you stop your test once your
p-value so you monitored the tournament
you stop it when it goes below your
threshold and you can just simulate that
and for example if you choose either
point one which is common in business
then your real error level is 80% so you
do almost everything wrong that's a very
big danger in the settings okay and
that's a cush kid that did the same
thing for the Bayesian setup yeah I
copied the plot with the rope thing and
on the left side you see the frequent
first version so the normal p-value
version and you see the false alarm wait
like the first positives going up up up
the more samples you get
when you stop with the rope so you just
say okay I stopped when my HDI falls
outside the world then it levels 10%
which is very nice and so you could do
continuous monitoring of your IB test
without having to fear of this multiple
testing stuff okay so this is nice but I
only could fit on this approach I only
could find simulations so simulations
good but I'm from mathematics so I like
poof's and like three weeks ago there
was a super nice article from Microsoft
and I also want to show this really
quick so another approach of a be
testing a bayesian word is to do base
vectors so you just look at the odds of
your of the probability of your
hypothesis so you know one hypothesis
given the data divided by the
probability of your zero hypothesis so
how probable is it that there is
something effect or that there's no
effect and then you look at the odds so
if this this thing would be like nine
then you would say my alternative
hypothesis is nine times more likely
than the other one and again with base
foods you can split that up into two
terms the base factor and the posterior
odds for simplicity we now take
posterior odds equal one so we say we
don't know we say they are equally
likely and then we are left with the
base vector so we wants to implement
that I also this with this you could
implement it in person but B is just a
beta function which is inside pi special
and then you just plug it in here I did
that you might get some problems with
underflow because the numbers get very
very small but then you can just take
the logarithm of this and use beta and
so if somebody wants to implement it and
now the guys for Microsoft Research
showed when we when we use this based
actor so stopping good so we say we stop
our a/b test if the base factor goes
over certain threshold let's say nine
so if base factor is above nine then
rejecting the alternative will expose us
to risk of a false rejection or
discovery of one divided by k plus one
and that's like a super strong result
because of a poor k equal to one that
would mean if we use the stopping rule
that we offer all our for loans only ten
percent would be wrong which is much
better than n frequentist approaches
yeah
okay now so now I always took like
uninformative priors and was that you
can guess one but here's also a very
nice article from the same people from
Microsoft that way down and expectation
maximization algorithm how you can fit
from your page past data the prior for
your model so you look for example you
have one page and you already won like a
hundred experiments there and then you
can already estimate how probabilities
that there will be a lift or not and
then you fit that as of cryo that's
called empirical base and then you have
a very very nice test with so you don't
have this subjectivity and you have
optimal stopping words okay my idea
which I want to test nests next so on
this base factorial level you have the
serum for good stopping and on the other
hand you have this rope model phone from
Khrushchev where you have this parameter
estimation so you really see how your
parameters are distributed there's
another article of Khrushchev which also
you can how you can combine both models
so we could take one branch to stop the
a/b test and the other branch to
evaluate all the parameters and have
really nice distributions and can really
say something like okay now we are like
90% sure that a speaker that has ambient
okay
you still have one slide left okay this
is just when to use synchrony testing so
in a lot of a lot of use cases that
doesn't really make sense although a lot
of people might use it so for example if
you have a fashion side and you have
completely different customers may be on
a Mondays and on a Sunday then you want
to test the whole time frame because
when you do sequential testing and you
on Wednesday here it already says
significant but you have completely
different users later on in the week
then you might want to test every week
so for our seasonality stuff it might be
better but if you have a decision we
will like evaluate every week then check
if it's significant or not and then do
another week and then do another week
then you again and sequential setup and
so this would be very useful for us I
think to stop negative experiments
because you you might have so not every
everything is neutral or success when
you run your really experimental company
so you might also very get worse results
than before and this can be a stopping
word so you could stop negative
experiments really quick without
guessing so what's the p-value you would
guess or you would constantly monitor
and get also this I firework emulation
and here you would have a proving
decision we will to when to stop a bad
experiment okay
examples these are four experiments
which of the left side the right side
which one was significant and you think
we put full on as in we deployed the
entire website so we're looking at the
values and how they fluctuated during
the experiment who says left
one end to ends who says right all right
what's the left side so you see that the
p-value converges to a really small
number after these are hours so I think
this was one week of experimentation and
after a couple days it already became
significant and they stayed there so
this is an example of how p-values can
fluctuate on the right side we have to
pay experiments so we didn't change
anything we're just testing whether
everything was still working fine and no
you can imagine that these are just four
examples but in some cases if people are
peeking here and this was maybe a bit
more but it was just reaching the
threshold that people get worried and
then they turn it off well nothing is
problematic here this is completely fine
so that's a if you peek which people say
they don't do but they do practice then
you see the P values are pretty
fluctuating a lot now the left eye seems
to be fine
but if you simulate a a experiment then
you can also get a lot of converging
p-values that that become and stay
significant over time and that's related
to it but then I said with the 80% false
false positives so this this might seem
fine but these could also be false
positive we don't know for sure
so we tried out all the stuff we
discussed before and I'm really happy
with my gifts we have slack so for a
short while now and everyone's sharing
gifts in slack at the moment this is my
first relevant gift that I can share on
slack with people this is the joint
posterior and these are actual
experiments and you see the first step
this is I think we're now at the end of
February on the left and stars in
December half December then you see this
really big bulb when we don't know
really what what is going to be the case
but the converse is quite soon up to a
point where it is
is it are these two significant
experiments or not what do you think
okay I think I'll have to wrap up these
are not the significant experiments so
it converges on the line so nothing is
wrong here and these are the ones who
did become significant you see it's a
really tiny effect booking we are
interested in in tiny effects I mean the
skill is huge so if if there's a point
five percent lift for all the bookings
per day per year that's gonna be quite a
lot of money that's why the both are
also small but this one's actually
conversion to ninety nine percent
probability that the variant is
different from the base so we have
nothing to vary about the four
experiments were fine according to the
basin approach I'm not going to show you
the stuff that we did wrong I don't
think my manager your life would like
that so let's wrap up thanks for your
attention if you have questions IDs
suggestions I don't know if I have to
park them or I can allow them so at the
moment we have time for a couple of
questions if anyone has them I'll bring
the mic over and you can ask questions
these people are booking we have the
first question over there hi sir I was
wondering about metrics that weren't
conversion rates do you want to count
measure counts or something like a
revenue metric what sort of
distributions would you use so the coach
cover in this article he used something
like the t-distribution that would also
work for revenue stuff so yeah but
that's a little bit more complicated you
would need to use Monte Carlo estimation
but the distribution he fits are very
nice it so I reckon I'm older and you
will also get get spread parameters for
outliers and stuff like that check the
article that's a good one
thanks with a very nice presentation so
when you do like the traditional be
testing so say like with this Z or a T
and then if you can get like an estimate
of how much samples you need before you
actually start right if you forget about
the sequential test and stuff yeah this
this biasion approach also give you
something like that because well some of
the websites are not a big as big as
yours right so I have to worry as well
like about how many samples that are so
possible what's so covered in the same
article of course that we have time for
one more question in that case these
folks will be around so if there's any
more further questions you can always
ask them can I please get a nice hand
for these two fine gentlemen let's get
speech